I was you know working working in the
street selling jewelry and I got plucked
from obscurity into the movie industry
if you're trying to do something that
you're not sure whether you can do I
think there's a great reward to that by
getting it do it you're only as good as
the team around you and you know the
people that you work with need
motivation
watch the top 10 with believe nation
what's that believe nation 7 I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from competing as a diver
and being on Britain's national swim
squad for 12 years to hustling perfumes
and watches on the streets to becoming
one of the most recognized and bankable
stars in Hollywood he's Jason Statham
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one play to your strengths
do you ever like get offered parts like
where you play something totally
different like a like you know I mean
like you're a kid you're concerned
father and you're into divorce and like
it's a real soft roll and you just want
to do a daughter got kidnapped and now
he must save her you know but I mean
something that's so out of the
mathematician is going for a bitter
divorce oh yeah
no I don't get off you want to do one or
no no really you know I mean is that I
only want to do things that I think I
could do a good job at and I think I'll
be no good at that really no I just you
know I'm not an actor really I mean I
used to you know what jewelry and pinch
jewelry on this remodeling a to your
right you know as a sportsman for years
I'm not really somethi spean that can
adopt and chameleon it himself into
different roles I just got into this by
you know being at the right place at the
right time I was you know working
working in the street selling jewelry
and I got plucked from obscurity into
the movie industry so it's not like I've
spent years honing out do different
accents or pretending yet I accept what
I'm good at or if I might not be good at
any of it but accept what I feel that
I'm confident and just try and go with
the flow in that direction rule number
two push yourself it's done why
seriously that Desai's anybody come to
you in anything you've ever done and go
again you're gonna do this this and
you're gonna like no freakin way
no because you know I've got a big ego
and I want to try and prove to myself
don't do it now it's a for me it's you
know I love trying to push myself I mean
I used to do high diving years ago and I
would sort of seeking out that
adrenaline and you know a lot of the
stunts or whatever you call them that we
get to do if there's a you know if
you're pushing your skill set a little
bit or if you're trying to if you're
trying to do something that you're not
sure whether you can do I think there's
a great reward to that by getting to do
it so I've always had a great kick out
of doing things
to do like
you know I pushed myself the same I
pushed myself to the limits of getting
it done so whatever the stunt is or
whatever the was whatever is required
you push yourself to maximize that
happening in a safe way and making it
look real
so you're always pushing yourself you
know you have to to get the adrenaline
going and you have to make it you have
to get physical otherwise it just looks
fake rule number three be open to new
things I wonder when you want to flip
the script and do a comedy or do
something where it's more your acting
the more so you're fighting yeah I'd
like to do it you know I'd love to do an
action comedy you know something
something along those lines it's just
finding the right script you know I get
sent a lot of stuff sometimes it's not
right so you have to you have to you
have to make a choice do you do it do
you not do it so if the right thing
comes my way I'm well open for uh for
doing something you know in the comedy
way rule number four trained martial
arts
did you ever train martial arts yeah
wait would you take I did a little bit
jiu-jitsu did a little bit kickboxing
I've done a you know pretty much they're
the two most specific and a lot of the
fight training that we do is all sort of
related to that a little bit of Judo I
did for a while just you know screwed
about and about in in different things
but never trying to achieve a certain
you know oh I need to get my black belt
in this I've no plans to get in a ring
no no you just like doing it though you
like it keeps you in shape
discipline of it I think it's great and
I think there's so much to be gained to
be got from doing martial arts it gets
people really sort of focused and I
think it really gives them a purpose and
there's a great community with with all
all kinds of competitive sport and uh I
would recommend it for anybody rule
number five
hustle after your diving career did you
have downtime before movies yeah I mean
the whole time I was doing this I was
you know working in the streets used to
sell perfume ah yes so that was it was
no got rid of the diamond and it just
kept continuing to do at my only way
that I knew our
which was on the street corners so how
would you sell something like you'd have
like a watch and you see a guy walking
by and would you just go sir come here I
never stop you know a single people out
you know it's you pull a pitch you just
talk about how you're gonna get you know
reduce things and how you're gonna give
them a bargain and how you're gonna you
know it makes sense to it's basically
you're you pulling the pieces look
there's like a stage where you you pull
the pitch basically get people's
attention you create a crowd and before
you start any of the the before you
start any of the sale technique you be
told that you know you watch what I'm
gonna do in a squeeze in left leg right
leg your body follows they call it
walking if you've got no money on you
now you'll be crying tears it's because
October cabbage is here left leg right
leg things that will go in four pairs
will go for pennies forget about what
they cost forget about what they worth
if you're with me here and now you'll be
absolutely getting a bargain here
squeezing so you just wrap rattling away
have you heard of Cartier madam what cot
will forget about what these cost in the
normal worth trade would obviously cost
you a lot of cash yeah well map in was
in these web I was in his warehouse last
night 3:00 in the morning is squeezing
and you just rattling away with silly
little things like that and then people
start to look and listen and then you
started to get into the details of the
sale you know and then you know you take
a rope chain and then you stop to reduce
it talk about where you know how you
know people say you know you're always
trying to get people relaxed so you're
always trying to do something with a
little bit of a joke and a jess right so
you're always trying to you know make
people feel at ease rule number six love
adrenalin recreationally are strap on
the fins and I go any any possible
opportunity if I'm close to anywhere
that would you know provide a decent
diver I get him I certainly make a
massive effort to do that and to make a
movie about it to be around the stunt
guys that I know I'll pop attorneys team
all of the New Zealand lads you know and
be in and around all this high-tech
equipment and rebreathers and do all the
training and be out in the OH
and you know drag behind a boat I'd
finally I loved all that kind of stuff I
love doing things that require you know
a little bit of focus and a little bit
of adrenaline it gives me my sense of
achievement rule number seven be a good
politician have you ever in your career
had to promote something that you didn't
love and you got to do it you don't have
to say what the movie was yeah yeah
plenty of time the point is it's very
hard to be to be open and frank about
the ongoings or whatever you know it's
let's say you work with a director who's
a bit of an idiot you don't get on you
don't really think he's that clever or
whatever this it's very difficult to say
that because it's just it's just
negativity so it's bad you know if
you're going up my mom always used to
say you are nothing good to say don't
say anything at all yes I wrote that
down so in a way it's it's better to not
get into that world because you just
sound like you're a bit of a negative
chap and you know not always if in all
kinds of business everywhere I think
people you know then you get the rough
with the smooth some dates some movies
are the best smoothest ride and you can
have the best fun and they've become a
you know a real purpose in your memory
and you have the you know you look back
with great fondness on those times and
others you just can't wait to get the
hell out of there and that's just nature
of the business no matter what you're
doing you have to really be a lot a good
politician and in what you do and how
you behave otherwise you'd you know
you'd be end up in punch ups every day
rule number eight get experience you're
always anxious if you're gonna do
something that you haven't done before
or if you're going to test yourself but
that's the reward if you can you know go
through that in a successful way there's
obviously some reward there but you know
it's all down to experience you know
nothing and I think I could have done
something as as heavy as this in my
former years you know I didn't have the
experience to draw from rule number nine
work in a great environment
I enjoy working with smart people I've
worked with a lot of people that ain't
so smart so when I do get to be
surrounded by you know such an amazing
set of people that you know this poor
Webster is a brilliant producer you've
got Chris mengas who's a great DP you've
got a fabulous production designer great
costume designers all those things are
very important when you come to you know
to make a film you need you're only as
good as the team around you and you know
the people that you work with working
with Vicky McClure and you know a guitar
the eyes that that kind of environment
is is so important on the quality of the
end product and rule number ten the last
one before a very special bonus clip I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
was wondering from say a female point of
view
with Rosie look at that let's go this
target hey I'm dr. tyberg
it's again the same thing yeah hey I'm
action
sorry-sorry is doctor a patient with
your I come on
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jason on how to make the best of
every situation that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what
needs to change in your environment to
make it great number two what small
change can you immediately make right
now and number three what's another
change you can make within the next week
how many times will you go to somebody
with a suggestion or being like look I
really think we should do it this way
and not be listened to before you just
snap it what do you do what are we doing
you know it's some babies you just don't
know it's some people have the thing
with the director they have to have a
vision right and it's sometimes not in
line with what the script is or your
perception of what the script is there's
a lot of moving parts with the scripts
with a movie as a finished movie you
know you've got a peek the vision of
what you might anticipate it to be can
be completely different by the time it's
finished and you have to accept that I
mean we're at the end of the day we
shouldn't be moaning because we're you
know we're hired actors you come in you
get paid shut your mouth do your work
and go home it should be a little bit of
that but sometimes you want to try and
get involved you just want to try and
collaborate and get things done and try
and you know help with the creativity
and sometimes you can do that and what
you also wanted so there's no click
clear cut line about you being an actor
come in say these lines and then go home
or you know come in and collaborate and
let's work this out and do things and
you know make the best of it if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check out the
Dwayne Johnson top 10 video I made I
think you'll like that one - the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I don't know how it happened but my
cousin who was on tour with us I said
just got busted with prostitutes and my
name is attached to it now